the US Army is looking beyond
traditional recruiting ads as it tries
to pitch itself to a new audience
gamers nearly 75% of men under 30 and
about half of young women say they play
video games the audience for competitive
gaming also known as eSports is expected
to rival the NFL by 2022 with as many as
300 million people only on CBS this
morning Tony de Coppola met with the new
with the Army's new recruiting commander
about how he hopes to turn virtual
fighters into real warriors it's only
goodmorning goodmorning gonna be a lot
of opinions about this one here's the
back story last year the army missed its
recruiting goal for the first time since
2005 two reasons for that the strong
economy also the slow collapse of
traditional recruiting like cold calls
so now Uncle Sam has a new strategy
going not just online but into video
games at this sold-out gaming convention
in San Antonio people dressed up like
their favorite characters including more
than a few make-believe soldiers but
there's one place where the uniforms
were real this is where the siege hands
off
Major General Frank moose head of the
Army's recruiting command
he's looking for the next generation of
American soldiers is there something
about what it takes to be a gamer today
and what you're looking for for Army
jobs that overlaps yes it's a
decision-making it's the ability taking
a lot of information quickly and to be
able to make a decision it's about
teamwork to help the mission the army is
putting together the first All Army
eSports team more than 7,000 active duty
soldiers are now competing for just 30
full-time positions playing games like
Call of Duty
fortnight and League of Legends happen
rounds in a row for the defense and
hoping to compete in eSports tournaments
across the country last year when we
didn't make mission we went down to the
recruiters and say okay what can we do
different and they said sir first we've
got to get off the phones nobody picks
it up anymore that's what got major
general mood thinking game on
you know the guys talk all the time
while they're playing the games so it's
like an old-fashioned television ad
except it's tucked right into the
natural flow of the gaming environment
yes this is the kind of setup that you
would imagine being able to begin a
recruiting conversation yeah sergeant
first class Chris Jones is leading the
new esports recruiting effort he says a
lot of what he does is explain that the
army is in all boots and bullets be not
only in the infantry but you could be in
cyber we have microbiologists we have
all these different career fields that
you know well that's why we're here to
tell you about it all right I'm gonna
give you the questions from a typical
recruit you got to give me the answer
okay all right can I have a dog
if you're a single soldier staying in
the barracks you cannot have a dog can't
have a car now if it's within your
budget yes and I keep smoking marijuana
in the military know currently that is
that is not allowed not even a little
bit not even on the weekend correct
it may be a disqualifier for a lot of
gamers correct no gamers may not fit the
old stereotype of America's Soldier as
much as I love my community we're not as
physically active miss people want us to
be but many seem to welcome the Army's
new interest honestly especially with
all the shooter games that we have
nowadays I think it's a great segue for
kids to kind of they're always like oh
this is kind of like the military either
cool thing about eSports is and Major
General move says the Army is being
honest about the realities of combat war
is obviously not a game are you guiding
these people into a career path that's
gonna get them killed there's risk in
everything we do the army there is a
risk but if you look at the you know the
percentage that are actually in direct
combat it's a low percentage there's a
lot of different jobs that you can do
and military specialties that are not
combat related but it's you know it's
part of being in the army it's part of
serving the army says the eSports team
should be ready to compete by the summer
and the other branches are also getting
into game in the airforce and sponsored
tournaments and the Navy is engaging
recruits with a new traveling simulator
I think a lot of opinions on this one
I'm not sure where I come down I wanna
hear what you guys think you said there
are some jobs there like that guy who
just was they look very happy I think
it's controversial in some communities
for recruiters to go into high schools
yes recruiters going into bedrooms
potentially through the headsets yeah
they're keeping up with the times I mean
that's a bathroom that's a way to get a
look at a short very true very true
I found your questions about marijuana
very interesting for a friend
thank you Tony I had